توترات ألمانية وبريطانية
مع روسيا
تعيد للأذهان الحرب العالمية الثانية،
وانضمام وشيك لأوكرانيا
إلى الاتحاد الأوروبي،
هل تجدي العزلة الأوروبية
نفعا ضد الدب الروسي؟
سيطرة روسية على أجواء أوكرانيا
مقابل دعم غربي لا ينتهي لحكومة كييف،
وتردد تركي قبل مواجهة محتملة
أمام روسيا،
وكل هذه الأحداث في كفة
وشروط بوتين في كفة أخرى
فمن سيطيح من؟
وكفة من هي التي ستنتصر؟
روسيا تستنكر دعم ألمانيا لأوكرانيا بالسلاح
وتقول:
سلاح ألمانيا سيوجه مجددا نحو الروس
وسنرد بعقوبات مضادة...
ورئيس الوزراء البريطاني جونسن يقول
إن فرض حظر طيران فوق روسيا
سيدفعنا لإسقاط مقاتلات روسية
والدخول في حرب معها..
فهل يعيد التاريخ نفسه للحروب العالمية؟
من جانبها رئيسة البرلمان الأوروبي تقول: ..
لن نستقبل المسؤولين الروس ولا أثرياءهم
لتكون روسيا في عزلة أوروبية....
وأضافت ،
نحن نرحب بطلب أوكرانيا للعضوية
في الاتحاد الأوروبي وسوف نعمل
من أجل تحقيق هذا الهدف..
... لأننا سوف نواجه المستقبل معا..
نحن إلى جانبكم في أيامكم القاتمة
والبرلمان الأوروبي فضاء لكم لمخاطبة العالم..
(أبرز التطورات والأحداث)
صور لأقمار صناعية تظهر
قافلة عسكرية متجهة نحو كييف
وعلى بعد ٦٠ كيلو متر منها،،
بالإضافة إلى قافلة أخرى...
الرئيس الشيشاني يعلن مقتل جنديين من قواته
في أوكرانيا..
رويترز تؤكد مقتل أكثر من ٧٠ جنديا أوكرانيا
في قصف روسي على بلدة أوختريكا...
مقاطع فيديو تظهر وصول جنود فرنسيين
وتعزيزات عسكرية إلى رومانيا
البحرية الأوكرانية تقول:
بلغاريا وبولندا وسلوفاكيا نقلت إلينا
٧٠طائرة حربية..
وروسيا ترد: لقد سيطرنا على المجال الجوي
الأوكراني بأكمله
لكن ذلك يقابله رد البنتاغون
الذي ينفي السيطرة الروسية الكاملة على الأجواء الأوكرانية..
وزارة الدفاع الروسية تعلن استهداف قواتها
الجوية ل٦ قوافل من العربات الأوكرانية المدرعة...
أمين عام حلف الناتو سيتم تفعيل خطة الدفاع
من أجل حلفائنا ليسمح ذلك بنشر قوة الحلف
عند الحاجة.
القوات الأمريكية المتواجدة في بولندا
تستعد قرب الحدود مع أوكرانيا
بحجة مساعدة الأمريكيين والفارين
من الغزو الروسي
وتحليق لقاذفة الصواريخ الأمريكية B52
فوق الأجواء البولندية.
كييف تطلب من حكومة أنقرة
إغلاق مضيق البسفور والدردنيل أمام روسيا
لمنع قواتها الإضافية من دخول البحر الأسود ...
وبعد تردد للحكومة التركية خرج بعدها
وزير الخارجية التركي تشاووش أوغلو وقال
: إن "تركيا لن تسمح بمرور السفن الحربية
عبر مضائقها استنادا إلى معاهدة (مونترو)
للملاحة البحرية.
الرئيس الأوكراني يعلن تأسيس فيلق دولي للمقاتلين
الأجانب لقتال الجيش الروسي
. وكييف تطالب الناتو بإقامة منطقة حظر جوي
غربي البلاد لكي لا تتعرض تعزيزات الغرب
للقصف من المقاتلات الروسية
(العنصرية تتواصل في دول الغرب):
حرس الحدود البولندي والشرطة الأوكرانية
طلبوا من أصحاب البشرة السوداء
العودة إلى مؤخرة طابور النازحين إلى بولندا
ومنحوا الأولوية للأوكرانيين..
العديد من العرب والأفارقة اشتكوا من تعرضهم
للتمييز حتى أن الشرطة منعتهم من ركوب قطار
إلى بولندا إلا بعد أن يصعد جميع الأوكرانيين،
خلال محادثة مع نظيره الفرنسي،
بوتين يبلغ ماكرون بشروطه الأربعة
لوقف العمليات العسكرية على أوكرانيا..
وماكرون يطالبه بإيقاف فوري لتلك للعمليات..
شروط بوتين
١. الاعتراف بالقرم أرضاً روسية
٢. إعلان حياد كييف
٣. نزع سلاح الدولة الأوكرانية
٤. تخلي الحكومة الأوكرانية عن نازيتها
وقبل إعلان هذه الشروط ب٣ ساعات
وصف بوتين المجتمع الغربي
ب (إمبراطورية الأكاذيب).
يذهب الغرب ويعودون بنتيجة واحدة،
هي أن الدب الروسي لن يتوقف إلا بتحقيق
جميع شروطه،،،
وسواء قبلوا بشروطه أو انتصر في الحرب
فكل الطرق تؤدي لتحقيق الغاية الروسية،،
وبينما يستمر الغرب بحربهم الجبانة
عن بعد كما هي عنصريتهم المقيتة
يتجرع الشعب الأوكراني
أسوء حرب يمكن تصورها....